is easier to please
be real man be real who's easier to
please
you know the answer everyone knows the
answer everyone knows the answer I think
men are more simple yeah
and you knew that as soon as I asked
yeah you knew the answer so it's so with
that knowledge when we all understand
that women are probably more complicated
and complex and it's gonna be harder to
please her because a lot of times like
you lots opinions and feelings change
like the wind blows bro like it's gonna
be a hard task to keep that person happy
majority of the time
are you trying though are you trying
that's the point if they're just like
literally leaving their marriage just
because they're just not happy that's
that's nonsense but if they're actually
trying to communicate it and the man is
just it's not getting anywhere then
there's a problem there that